what's up everyone james murphy here
from m coding
back with another video on python
weirdness do you know
what the comma equals operator does in
python
if you know the answer to this trick
question let me know down below in the
comments
otherwise here are some choices
in this situation x is one y is the list
containing two
and we're looking at x comma equals y
afterwards we're printing out the value
of x so
is x the integer one
is x the integer two
is x the singleton list containing one
is x the tuple containing one
and list of two
or is this just a syntax error
pause the video now if you need some
time to think about it
all right done thinking about it so do
you know what
the comma equals operator does let's
find out by running it
x gets the value 2. did you get it right
well if you're like me then you probably
thought this was just a syntax error
when i first saw this in a real code
base
i thought it was a syntax error and
maybe that i accidentally put the comma
in
myself well that's not true as you can
see
this does something so
if you're not sure about why this
printed out too let's look at
a simpler example but first
let me give you a hint i'll run my code
formatter on it
did you see what happened here let me do
it again
ready format it moved the comma
do you know the answer now
if not let's just go through it here is
a simpler example suppose
we have a function you know do something
and x is 1
and y is 2
then we can say x comma y
equals y comma x
what this syntax does is it will swap
the values of x and y
it's kind of doing a little bit of
pattern matching
let me put in some unnecessary
parentheses here
it's kind of saying look at this pattern
on the left
x comma y and try to extract out values
for x and y
based off of what's on the right hand
side where you see
y comma x
in this case it kind of makes sense that
it would swap the values of x and y
because i would say well matching the
pattern x should be the thing
inside the tuple which is at the zeroth
index
so that's y and y should be the thing
which is inside the tuple
at the first index which is x so
afterwards
x is equal to what y was and y is equal
to what x was
well this would work just as well if
this was a list or any other
iterable with two elements in it and
here's where we see our previous example
x comma equals y
if you have a list of just one thing or
a tuple of just one thing
the syntax looks a little different so
suppose
x was like this
a tuple of one thing in
in python gives you
the following syntax you need to have
this extra trailing comma
after the single element in the tuple
because otherwise it just looks like you
parenthesized x
and we don't want parentheses to be
creating tuples unless you really meant
to
so in this case if you want the left
hand side to be a tuple
you need to put that comma in but these
parentheses
are still optional
so now do you see why x comma equals
something
gives you the value that it did before
well our previous case looked like this
y
was 2 and we just said x
comma equals y so now y
here is just like we're putting two in
so it's saying pattern match this tuple
of one thing
with this list of one thing
that's why x gets the value two at the
end of it
make sense now is there any
real case where you might want to use
this syntax
admittedly if you're using this syntax
you might be in a gray area at the very
least
absolutely do not format it this way
put the spaces in the right place
otherwise you're just going to confuse
people
so i have come up with one case
where it might actually you know makes
sense to have something like this
let's suppose that i have two sets
and i know that their intersection has
only one element so just for
demonstration purposes
let's say that we have a list of primes
you know 2 3 5
7 11. and we have a list of evens
which is 2
4 6 8
10. let me actually make these sets
not lists
now i know that the set of evens and the
set of primes only has one thing in
common and that's two
so i could say x comma
equals with the correct spacing of
course
primes dot intersect
intersection with the evens
and then print x
so in this case if i call do something
now we see that again it prints out two
so that's one case where if you know
ahead of time
that there's only one thing in the right
hand side
then you might actually want to use this
comma equal syntax
instead of having a temporary variable
you know intersection
equals this and then x equals
intersection dot pop to get the one
element out
there you have it that's the comma
equals operator in python
hey thanks for watching again if you
like the video
remember to like comment and subscribe
also i offer online python courses
so if you would like to learn python
from me
then go ahead and drop your contact info
at the link in the description
and i'll let you know when online python
courses
are available